hey hey final for all these smokes god
these isn't just flown by
um but yeah okay so this is a the
beginning of the final four episodes of
laser bender this is the sozin's comet
the Phoenix King I believe I'm saying
that right um they gained the title red
I mean and uh uh where the hell's Aang
it's just he it goes Life of Pi on us
he's suddenly on this island out of
nowhere and can never be found again
whatever but uh okay cool so that that
has me intrigued this is the episode
where uh they're trying to figure out
exactly how they're gonna defeat what
particular Liang is going to defeat the
Fire Lord if he's a pacifist and only
does violence in self-defense ah you
said violence is never the answer but
self de vente well change in a bit ly
nitpick um but it bomb like he doesn't
want to kill the Fire Lord
aah Zuko lets out this bit of
information that it absolutely has to be
done before the comet because the Fire
Lord has this plan that he's gonna
literally take over everything you know
and like obliterate uh you know that the
earth Kingdom as well it sounds like if
I heard that right and he just he wants
to be ruler of the world frame I've not
just majority of it I need like all of
it and a Zula he's gonna have be ruler
of the fire Kingdom and he's just gonna
be the friggin ruler of everything else
so um yeah that's creepy uh just and he
has the power to do it and Zuko lets
them know saying hey you can't wait till
after the comet because that was what
they were originally gonna do and that
they have to really start buckling down
and be serious about this cuz beforehand
I guess they were like they needed a
break and we're playing at the beach and
stuff like that so it goes like you know
hey well wise up which is always kind of
maybe it's the workaholic in me but I'm
sorry like what are you doing there's
work to do don't play at the beach you
fools
oh so hyper much identified with Zuko in
those scenes um so uh yeah and then Aang
but Aang is really at a crossroads he
does not know what to do
with the fire Lord he does not want to
kill him it goes against everything he's
been brought up to believe and he
doesn't stand by it
and he doesn't know what path he's going
to choose so the men tonight he gets up
walks on two walks over to this island
that apparently shows right across with
him and the more the island disappears
and they go to what's in it was a Jew
the the Bounty Hunter great to see her
again that's as much as I didn't like
that Alto uh episode I like that she
came back because she was a cool
character and to get the mole and they
go searching for him so uh yeah
everything about it indicates it's the
beginning of you know an episode at not
an episode of like a two-parter in this
gate four-part er uh so it's hard to say
a ton about it except that I
legitimately don't know what they're
going to do with Aang not wanting to
kill and the and having to take down the
Firelord because it's yeah at one point
it's funny because they show a baby
picture of the Fire Lord and aang is
trying to talk about what he's gonna do
to try and defeat him and at first I was
sort of thinking like are they gonna try
and like you know sort of get to his
soft side or whatever and Zuko that
beats me too it's like oh yeah maybe we
can show his baby picture and you know
ease to his soft side it's like oh good
they're not they're not doing that um
but I I really don't know I don't know
what path are gonna choose to finish him
off so I'm really intrigued by that this
is one of the few times you know I get
with a lot of these family shows you
sort of know where it's gonna go or have
a general idea but I'm going into this
like really scratching my head like what
is he going to do what is gonna happen
here um so you know is the Fire Lord
even gonna be destroyed or something
else gonna have to do them is gonna be a
supernatural and then are they gonna
find a way around it or it it seems like
they would find a way around it because
I don't think that's like the best thing
they want to promote and to show that
is also primarily seen by kids you know
is that you know hey all this talk about
whether or not it's right to kill it is
if something tells me they wouldn't go
that route but either either they find a
way around it or they find a way around
it and somehow he dies anyway but not
buy eggs and that's my guess um but I
don't know how I don't know what
conclusion they're going to come to
necessarily so um we know Zuko's not
gonna do it or at least they were
building up a he's not gonna do it so
well
el are you watching this priority know
what happens and but me mid beginning of
four-part ending I have no clue so I
like that again that this show is so
great at throwing these surprises at me
and building up to an ending that not
only do I not know how they're going to
and how they're gonna get to what
they're trying to achieve but I don't
know how they're going to achieve it or
even in this case what they're going to
achieve we just know that the fire Lord
has to be defeated we don't know if he's
gonna be killed if he's just gonna be
stopped or he's gonna be in prison
somewhere or some sort of other
supernatural element or it's gonna be
talked out of it or if they're gonna
appeal to something I don't know but I'm
really looking forward to it uh I don't
know what else to really say about this
one like I said everything about source
starts off as like a beginning to a
four-part ER so I'll pop I don't have
too much this one so but um yeah like I
said I'm just I'm legitimately intrigued
on what they're gonna do and I look
forward to seeing what they're gonna do
so uh yeah beginning of the final for
all the sports fans are go you
talking about and but my geek peeps know
what I'm talking about so uh that's
about it I'll see you in part two